[Music]
what's up welcome to another episode of
[ __ ] corner when we decide if this
muhfucka is a cut or not I like to read
these posts on reddit it's called am I
the [ __ ]
huge shout out to read it am i me at all
how much content it's so good I like to
be the judge of human beings because
sometimes I like to believe that I know
morally what's best and what's the worst
for people but this one is titled am I
the [ __ ] for banging my brother from
bringing his Indian girlfriend to my
wedding
please elaborate okay because so far I'm
saying yes you were an [ __ ] and all
does they know she's Indian curry knew
exactly what you were thinking because
they said tidal sounds very bad and
horribly racist but let me clarify my
brother he's 25 has been dating an
american-born girl to Indian parents
since last year she's 20 feet her
parents do not like their relationship
because he's white and probably prefer
her to find an Indian man he has been
trying to gain their approval but
failing and from what he said they
continue to shrug him off and actively
exclude him if she tries to bring him to
her family events this has annoyed me
because my brother is one of the nicest
people I know in the meantime I proposed
to my girlfriend and we're sending out
invites to everyone I came to the
difficult discussion that since his
girlfriend's family will not accept him
we will not accept her I talked it over
with my girlfriend and told her how
strongly I feel about this and she
agreed I didn't want to spring this up
on her so I asked his girlfriend if we
could meet up and I sat down with her
and explained that in good conscience I
could not invite her to our wedding if
her family cannot accept my brother and
I essentially balled it down to if they
don't want my brother we don't want you
I told her she will be banned from all
of our future family events until
something changes with her parents in
regards to my brother she got upset
about it and this caused a huge divide
in my family my brother obviously is
against it but I wanted to do it out of
out of support for him other relatives
agreed this was the right thing to do
but I've been seeking judgment from
outside of my family to gain a clearer
perspective if I was being an [ __ ] in
making this decision because he's just
doing the same thing that her family's
doing but she's have any [ __ ] control
over that you could be the bigger person
and invite them in while nothing to do
with her the invite is not to her family
it's to [ __ ] her right and her like I
don't think you guys are thinking like
white people because because of my
unique perspective right I'm able to
give some sort of context of this oh yes
oh no he's an elf yeah Hey we have Shawn
here who was raised by a white man so he
can battle you on this wait were you
really
mr. beds white I had no idea that's
actually a very interesting couple I
don't think I've ever seen a white and
Indian oh why do you what everybody yeah
cuz we do you're doing it and nobody
seems to notice I've seen every
combination sex perspective yeah it's
never seen that before I actually seen
it a lot in England yeah there are a lot
of any there's more Indians yeah yeah so
I saw a lot of like Indian and white
couples there from both you know like
white guy Indian girl Indian guy white
girl whatever they're there together
right right but maybe because of the
history yeah his house they also added
here I just want to clarify too all the
posters that I'm not doing this to
punish her or her family she still hangs
around her family a lot and given that
her family is disrespectful to my
brother I feel that it makes her toxic
and I don't want toxic people at my
wedding so if she this owns her families
and land she can come so he just say if
you just say if she decides her family
[ __ ] just go ahead and do it she just
owns her Indian family said she can
cover the web yeah okay so we all agree
that this [ __ ] an [ __ ] yeah this
would have been a better solution just
invited her you're not dealing with
their parents you could be the bigger
she's not there not even inviting the
parents what I don't get is why is he
making this personal because I even his
old brothers like hey this is not cool
yeah it was but I'm doing this for you
you don't see this he doesn't like her
he feels slighted because he's taking
their that family's rejection if his
brother is like oh you don't accept me
either then so I'm not gonna accept
yours or whatever so it's like this
weird like proxy war of [ __ ] fans yet
my family online is he's making it about
him right yeah and that's what's
[ __ ] right yeah the end of the day
it's about his brother and what his
brother wants and if his brother is like
yo dude why are you making this so
complicated then he's [ __ ] over his
brother yeah you know some people they
get more mad when you [ __ ] with their
homie than when you [ __ ] with them yeah
people are the [ __ ] lamest people on
earth I'm sorry you know why though it's
the same as when I meet a girl and then
she's kind of okay and then I meet her
friends and I'm just learning about this
girl and her friends like if you hurt
her I swear to god and I'm like I'm just
getting to know this girl [ __ ] you and
[ __ ] her they're gonna do something what
are you gonna do what you gonna do
Sandra 25 years in jail because of you
you [ __ ] [ __ ] with your friend I
swear to god you better treat her good
my friends people out there I know what
I'm saying is usually it's just people
fronting cuz they're such good fans and
they're so annoying and they're so fat
thank you
only in this case it's all you do is the
truth I have nothing wrong with fat
people it's just that when you're fat
and you tell me not to [ __ ] with your
friend or else whatever what is that why
is that such a stereotype and it's why I
just want scene in life why by the way I
met a lot of cool fat people I know
right really cool fatty you know
it doesn't work and you guys
relationships have you guys had issues
with other families like your girlfriend
would why is dude yeah yeah how's one
here like yeah with it like Asians
there's racism Ryan people looking down
to me and all that and to me it was kind
of ridiculous because I'm here being
judged as his low class creature and I'm
like wait but my family is educated and
you guys aren't and also I'm richer than
you yeah and I didn't understand why
their family was so judgmental what were
they judging like wow you can't bring
this dentist home like oh you got with
this Japanese kid and like what like and
and I'm just like wait why is that a bad
thing right like I didn't know there was
this is just their ignorance this girl
that I dated she was like yeah my dad
hates Vietnamese people she she was
Chinese my dad hates Vietnamese people
he said don't make Vietnamese people
they beat their wives and then she also
told me that he said don't date
Filipinos cuz that the dirt Asians I was
like holy it some racist [ __ ] it's like
mainly within Asians too cuz I needed
this other girl she's like oh I heard
Japanese guys beat their wives same
thing told her daughter dude my
father-in-law he's Filipino full
filipino and he always talks about every
time he takes the trash out he's oh sure
the brown guys gotta take the trash
that's so funny
yeah one of those things where I never
even heard that in my whole life until I
met him yeah I never heard my old man
say like brown guys you just you just
glared at them from the right moms like
like calling the police like there's a
brown guy somebody's wearing a hoodie in
my neighborhood yeah
that's life some family members are like
that where it's like a loyalty thing
where it's like off you [ __ ] with them
that I don't [ __ ] with you cuz I think
it's so weird to me cuz for me like okay
I have a pretty kind of shady relation
with my stepmom and I think that's based
mostly on her issues with my grandmother
and it just kind of got rolled on to the
children but not for me as an adult
if I was an SM situation I wouldn't roll
that on to the kids because they're
they're a separate relationship for me
you're being a dick to me I'm not gonna
hate your kid you know that isn't but it
makes sense for some people I for some
people that just is the thing it's that
stupid tribalism dude it's hard right so
okay so I got my in-laws there's
something going down recently and it's
pretty big [ __ ] but I can't get into it
too much but one of the cousins came
over to borrow chairs from one of my
in-law uncles okay do the slamming on P
and B no the in-law uncle was pissed at
what was going on inside the family Oh
and so he wouldn't let the cousin borrow
chairs and he's like hey you want to
know why I won't let you borrow these
two chairs then ask your mom what she
said about grandma like trust me people
can bring pettiness in the [ __ ] cab
any race can bring pettiness and
anything and it always boils down to the
most uneducated group of like Minton
like mines right cuz I had a friend who
was dating Hughes Chinese is dating a
Vietnamese girl and her family swore
that they were having dinner with
Chairman Mao himself after he left the
dinner they're like you know he's a
communist he's like my family ran away
from China and communism just as the
same as your Vietnamese family but
they're like we don't trust the Chinese
because they're communists what he lives
in America exactly in there they fled
China for the same reasons so they
should bond over this fact but their
family was so [ __ ] like kind of
cavemen in their heads they believed
that all Chinese were communist and
indoor like we hate communists that's
why we ran away from Vietnam so you need
to be with a good Vietnamese boy that is
an anti-communist and then I was like
what the [ __ ] and to top it off that
father was he had something to do with
some type of like nation trade like it
was like a position where you should be
more open-minded because you're in a
position where you you're dealing with
so many cultures like working out of
embassy or some kind of [ __ ] so it's
just crazy how people's minds
and for me whenever I feel that or hear
that from family members it almost makes
me want to run from the person that I'm
with right yeah that's marrying into
that family I feel like my IQs gonna
drop yeah getting into that family yeah
cool cuz that's what my dad said do he
was just like remember like you like you
can't pick your own immediate family but
you can always pick the family to marry
into it was like yeah that's a fair
point kinda what did she so hot
that's true he didn't add that
stipulation on the end of the video
hopefully he's estranged from her family
she's so hot blonde hair blue eyes she
has some Nazi family okay that's a lie
she's so fine but she but if she's not
though before if she's not you guys
could go to Aruba together her mom's hot
start fresh your mom's hot
hey so time to have as though you have a
hot person their braces and they're like
okay how am I gonna make this work yeah
I think it's worth it what ifs what if
she's not the races though her family
members are she's estranged from them
because that would mean a lot from what
she's doing her like what if she's
trying to bring two together and she's
like we need to make world peace no what
if okay what if yeah she's a racist but
she's so yeah that's hard like a bassist
I mean let me just dater just daters
pretty bad but but I'm a believer of my
leadership skills and I think I could
[ __ ] the common to racism out of it she
could tongue the racism she could take
it all out I got out of you or take it
out of her to get out of her no with her
tongue off the Joe's [ __ ] it's an
interesting interaction I could
visualize it so easily thanks to knowing
them
[Music]